if you want someone to find you
attractive
tilt your head down slightly when
talking to them maintain eye contact and
talk slower
hello ew what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party
[ __ ] this is unwaxed get in loser we're
going shopping with sophia and sistine
stallone we just become best friends
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sisters sophia and
sistine wait
okay can i just so um sistine has been
having but this has been something
that's happened for a while but sistine
has this problem with her eye that it
just won't stop twitching and i just
looked at her and she told me this
morning that it was but while we were
talking like 10 minutes ago 10 minutes
ago two seconds ago
it just completely went wrong
what's going on with me it's gross
someone said i need to eat more bananas
my mom says i need to sleep more i went
to bed at 9 00 p.m last night i'm not
sure what it is but i have chronic eye
twitches it's really bad please let me
know if you have any advice for that
well no it's also that your eye twitches
aren't just
little ones that just flare it's like it
almost looks like it can move your face
so you know i just realized in a way
this could really hurt me because what
if someone thinks i'm winking at them
and then they get the wrong impression
i feel like they're gonna think of a
spasm
i don't think it's a very hot wink
excuse like a can you wink hot yeah do
it i wanna hear something funny when i
was younger just a fun fact about my
winking
i don't know why i thought this was such
a smart thing to do but i saw the girls
that would like be able to wink at a guy
across the room and i thought that was
like super hot and i think i was 14 at
the time so i practiced i was practicing
with both eyes so i can do both eyes
so in case there's a guy over here i'd
go like that
in case there's a guy here
depending on where they are
how dumb is that is that supposed to be
your hot wing you just did well no that
was do your hot wink that was like you
literally like this
that's bad
do it better i can't
it's like well it's not like a pressure
thing inside look at you
oh actually it's so funny that you just
went up and down i love making you do
stuff that makes you uncomfortable it's
so funny that you just dropped your eyes
and then looked back up as if there was
a person standing there because
i've been getting all of my sources
for relationship advice for dating tips
for
self
improvement everything on tick tock yeah
and there's a lot of those right now
there's so many of them and i actually
have to read you a few of them it was
one of the videos i saw was how to make
him fall in love with you and i said i
gotta watch this hold on i gotta pull it
up i saved it just for you guys
so you're getting all your relationship
advice from a random tick tocker yes
who's just trying to get clout
well no
what if he's legit although it is kind
of where the video has a bunch of
captions that come up on the screen of
what you're supposed to do but in the
background he's like doing crunches it
was really confusing
how are you going to trust a guy that's
doing crunches in his bedroom at 2 am
telling you how to fall in love with
someone you're like this is the perfect
person to go to
if i need a relationship advice okay
here it is this is a 15 year old boy see
look he's doing crunches
in the background what he looks like
he's working out it says psychology
tricks
if you want someone to fall in love with
you use the triangle method
look at their left eye then down at
their lips and then at their right eye
and smile
oh okay i've heard of that one but you
just did it
kind of no not really i was just
checking out here's another one
if you want someone to find you
attractive
tilt your head down slightly when
talking to them maintain eye contact and
talk slower
hello
ew have more and more if you want
someone to be more attracted to you say
you have something on your face or hair
then reach to get it
so they'll know you look out for them
what reliable this is my favorite one
this is my this one is guaranteed to
work keeping full eye contact for 15
seconds has been proven as a way to make
someone fall in love with you if i stare
at someone for 15 seconds and they stare
at me for 15 seconds we will fall in
love
yeah i should have a boyfriend then
because at this point i stare at
everyone you know i have a staring
problem
and i know they're staring at me because
i'm making them uncomfortable i have
horrible eye contact i'll be talking to
you but looking over here and people
think it's very rude so saying gets mad
at me because every time i think when
we're talking and i know there's someone
attractive behind her and she's trying
to have a conversation with me i really
won't pay attention to her at all you
know my demeanor changes whenever
there's a cute guy you are so [ __ ] i
hate when you do that
sophia it is like you are like a dog
with a bone you see a treat behind me
and it's like i don't even exist anymore
i could be saying something extremely
important or perhaps emotional and she
would have no idea what i'm talking
about not at all because there's a cute
six foot seven guy behind me like eight
foot six person page
eight foot six person not just sports
and oh my god what we did last night
wait what did we do last night
so
there's this website
[Laughter]
there's this website called wikifeet
wiki feet
someone's nodding their head do you know
what wikifeed is okay let me just
explain it it's basically a wicked keys
yeah my feet that are the size of skis
yes have a page on wiki feet yeah so we
googled it i was like oh let's just see
if sophia and i have a profile on wiki
feet which is basically wikipedia for
your feet and then people give you a
rating and then you get a name for
reviews they give you reviews and a
score
i
had
an incredible score with over 400 votes
on my feet
i did too i was pretty surprised because
i have a little space between my feet
i hear that five stars i have beautiful
feet
oh my god this is real i told you wait
don't look at my feet now i'm
uncomfortable don't look at my mind you
guys i was actually shocked by this
because i have
platypus feet they're very flat yeah
there's no arch and they're huge they
are pretty big
they're like they are skis
we're looking at photos of our feet
right now is there anything worse than
it looks like
you're you're uh what is that part
that's next to you these are nice well
it looks what is my ankle
it looks like you sprained your ankle
this is not gonna be on a thumbnail i
swear to god oh my god we are not click
baiting with my feet you guys i'm sorry
i do not understand a foot fetish i
don't get it
it is so normal i love my feet because i
can pick up anything oh my god sophia
wait this is so funny so we spent
thanksgiving
wait this is so funny you don't know
that i saw you did
[Laughter]
we this thanksgiving with um another
family that we had family family
familia another family
all right oh i'm by the way so we're
looking at a photo of my feet and it was
a photo i posted i did an art thing and
the comments i got about nice feet nice
feet i literally screwed myself in the
like ask or wait i had to describe
myself myself in the ass
i can't think today
and my toes are just like kind of his
face so i could
grab anything like that so sophia was
painting with her feet that day go check
out our instagram if you haven't seen it
but anyway we're spending thanksgiving
with this other family and sophia we
were at the dinner table and sophia
dropped some food on the floor what you
did i don't know if it was thanksgiving
or breakfast the next day but you
dropped some sort of cereal or food or a
fork it's not red or like a red i would
say it's like sloppy instead of bending
down she literally reaches for it with
her toes
and picks it up
with your feet and then plops it into
your head to put it back on the table
i
was
gagged there's no way
it was disgusting
bend down you lazy [ __ ] what are you
doing picking [ __ ] up with your face
yeah it's like second nature i really
won't pick up anything with my hands if
it's over there hold this okay
i need to stop crying because
by the way i will not eat anything else
of course like i just might promise you
but when we were kids we actually used
to have competitions to see like
if we could pick up certain items with
our feet and you would always win and i
always like it ended up being heavy
things like a tv remember no no i could
pick up anything my feet it's kind of
weird
i think it's a talent and actually i
remember this one time i was at school
this is like another
oh god like i was you know i was such a
weird kid in like elementary school you
need to talk so basically um i used to
be able to sit in this very weird way
where i could like invert my knees and
like sit in like a t
remember how i used to sit like this
yeah it almost looks like your legs look
like an iud yeah but literally my life
looks like an iud shoe yeah i remember i
was with all the boys and i
crushed on one of them
and so we had i told her that i could
pick up as many raw like count as many
rocks as i can pick up with my toes in
like 10 seconds and so in front of
everyone i'd grab the rock and throw it
to the other side
in front of everyone and all these guys
and it was just
horrified and that's was this that was
the start of my so i'm assuming that he
didn't like you because of it no he
asked me though to play like handball
because i was the best of out of the
girl she's probably like she's very
handsy she's good with her hands she
goes ahead and maybe she's going with
her feet too oh my god it was bad oh so
i was on tick tock you know you just
brought up the tic toc psychology i have
more of them if you want to read them
anyway go on well you know there was one
that i saw the other day it was like
tips to make him fall in love with you
something like two that looks like he's
17 years old and he's like flexing and
also it pops up at the end
one of them is just like don't answer
him
oh i saw that one it was a vanessa [ __ ]
boy yeah yeah those are always popping
up in my paycheck and i'm not even
researching it but i freaked out why two
days ago because this girl
wrote um
this new instagram update is like
ruining my life now you can go check out
who is watching your page the most by
going on to privacy going settings all
of this stuff
and i was like
uh you know me i like to look at people
i was like no
and so i rant rant instagram like
bunched in my fingers and like got onto
the page and i couldn't find it and then
i started reading through the comments
and it wasn't true but for a second i
thought my heart fell out of my body
because it was like obviously like the
guys i'm talking to
i'm like number one
i'm pretty sure there's a new update
that if you screenshot
your messages with someone on the dms
they get a notification
see everyone's eyes just bugged out see
yeah
i think that's a real one i think it is
we tested it out
yeah probably you guys have the most
recent update i don't i do
yeah so but you freaked out about it
yeah i freaked out and i i thought it
was fake and we tried it out with
scarlet but i don't know if yours was
updated or hers was updated or what it
was but it didn't work
but seriously like don't i feel like the
amount of things i've screenshoted in
research
yeah
and we can't do our stalking techniques
anymore no well no i'm trying i mean i
told you i've graduated from
stalking people and really looking them
up but still
if that happened like there was always
those third-party apps used to use that
you could track like who would unfollow
you yeah i used to love those in middle
school i'd be like oh this [ __ ]
do they still work i don't know
definitely not it wouldn't work for us
though because i feel like it'd be hard
to with our
i wish
instagram had like a ghost mode or
privacy mode so you could go on it and
no one's notified that you were on it
because that's also a little trick where
say if
i used to do this all the time because
my
old boyfriend would never message me
back
but he would always be on instagram and
i would know it because you could go on
their dms and they'd say last active
10 minutes ago so i'm like oh okay so
you're on your phone all right all right
and
that way do you know what i'm talking
about yeah i do oh oh i do know what
you're talking about i used to love that
one i know and they took it off they
took it off you could see exactly when
they liked stuff
okay maybe this is a hack i just thought
about this could it be possible if you
wanted to watch someone's story
that you and you don't want them to see
that you watched it could you watch the
story block them
and then okay that seems like wait
listen
you watch it no we can quickly block
them and then unblock them would it
still pop up
only one way to find out i actually kind
of want to test that out because if that
works but who cares if he saw that you
looked at his story i do why because i'm
indifferent when we're going out like i
don't care if he's like i'm cool i don't
care if i like what you're doing on
saturday night but you do look at you
you care so much i don't look how much
you care right now i don't
i do
[Laughter]
you know what
oh my god
what
i spent an embarrassing
amount
of money at a store that i thought i'd
seen the last of since fifth grade
and i spent it yesterday
i went to abercrombie oh you went to
abercrombie the one in oh yeah so i went
to abercrombie and i was thinking you
know maybe i'll get a a beanie you know
it's
winter season let's let's let's invest
in a big a beanie in a in los angeles
and i go in and i was shocked how great
it is it was just
great i went in yesterday and i walked
around i'm like i will buy out this
store if i don't leave right now i did
i bought out the store did you get all
the body suits and stuff
nah i can't do a bodysuit i love a ball
there's too much tug and pull it's just
then when you got to pee you got to take
off the internet oh she's too tall it
has a long torso that's not what i meant
that is exactly what you meant because
that part makes you uncomfortable if
you're thinking if i'm thinking about
the part that makes you stretched out
sophia ew
is that ill
it's io it gives you a wedgie
yeah body suits give you wedgies but not
when you have a short torso
well
i guess but anyway no you when you have
to go to the restroom and then you have
to take off the entire body and then
you're standing in a public bathroom
stall completely naked
you just move it to the side excuse me
you move it to the side you don't
freaking take off the entire thing you
don't you go ass naked yeah
i never thought to do that
it's like a baby i mean like a bathing
suit's different but like a one-piece
bathing suit like you would literally
take it off head to toe yeah no you can
just like
move it
damn
and wipe like that's not that hard damn
you wipe no i'm just kidding
wait you don't shake
well anyway so i go into abercrombie and
i was like okay no one can know that
for example i told you a really cool
brown jacket the other day from
abercrombie and
it's almost embarrassing if you say it's
from abercrombie so i'm just gonna say i
got it at a flea market or something
because i feel like the little moose
logo that used to be there
just sort of
made everyone seem so uncool
back then
if you wore abercrombie which everyone
did you would be seen as dorky or uncool
but i only wore abercrombie i don't
understand why also abercrombie
bring back the shirtless models used
outside you have outside yes i'm sorry
like bring out the guys
okay if you guys don't know it was the
best thing ever you don't know what
we're talking about they used to have
these really cute shirtless like tables
that were like tan and beautiful stand
outside of the store it was definitely
their after school
i would go after school almost every day
just to see those models they would just
stand outside and then they would pump
the air vents with that clone
yes
and you would just you walk by you're
not even near abercrombie you're on the
second floor like you've been walking
inside over
oh my god
i was but i was that girl that like
asked to take a photo with the guy yeah
she and i did
i gotta find this like a celebrity like
my side bangs thinking like maybe he'll
think about it
that's like saying how every girl thinks
they can get jack harlow you just
thought you could get the abercrombie
guy one day yeah like one day you're
walking past the story he used to stop
you i honestly believe justice sneakers
i thought though for years i wish this
is my new year's resolution and i have a
lot of them and i do want to get into it
but i wish i had the mentality
just sort of with confidence that i did
back then
i was very insecure but in in different
ways
i really thought i was a main character
and i thought i was a pick me girl me
too like i really did like i'd go to
concerts we'd go to a maroon 5 concert
we'd see justin bieber we've seen one
direction and i genuinely got ready to
be like he's gonna point he's gonna
notice me in the entire arena of people
and he's gonna invite me backstage and
we're gonna drink soda like i literally
believed that don't hear me funny i saw
a tick tock that this girl made as a
parody because of how we used to think
when we were younger a lot of our girls
used to do that so she made a joke that
she was at a one direction concert and
how she was different was by reading a
book during the concert
that's what you would do that's what i
would do but the thing is like that was
how every single girl felt like they
thought that maybe like he would see her
you would notice me oh my god like the
amount of eyeliner i put on under my eye
oh no don't even trying to look older
i'm wearing shirts that said no
photoshop
like like he doesn't feel like she's all
natural
she stands out from the crowd she's not
photoshopped
that's on her shirt no it was it was so
embarrassing but i do want to get into
new year's resolutions because the new
year is almost coming up and it's kind
of crazy we've done this podcast i
remember we shot sort of a christmas
special new year's episode you know last
year
like your resolution i should probably
go back and listen to what it was
i hate resolutions you know what i kind
of make up some [ __ ] every year like
i want to be this but then i it's so
hard to remind yourself to do that all
the time yeah i was like i'm going to
eat healthy but i do want yeah no i
can't do stuff like that because that
lasts about two days yeah but i do want
to
shift my mentality more because i feel
like this year
i've learned the most about myself and
i've been like the happiest with myself
that i've been in other years and there
are things that i definitely want to
tweak in terms of
things that i can control like i want to
be a better friend to people i want to
be that girl you know when you get a
text from a friend that's always
checking up and always reaching out and
and saying like i miss you let's get
dinner like yeah i love my friends but i
just forget to do that stuff i tell you
to do that i know and i'm bad at it so i
want to be better at that that's a
really good thing to point out because i
think a lot of people struggle with
having that confidence to be the first
to reach out and just say hey like i
haven't seen a while how are you doing
like let's get coffee when you're free
and they always feel and they always
want to do oh my god anytime someone
reaches out and says that to me that i
like
i'm always like oh my god like that's
that's sweet i've never thought in my
head ugh like
they care about me yeah god forbid so i
think that's good to not overthink that
i think for me i feel the same way like
i don't think i've had as
transformative as a year as you've had
but i do think i've seen things that
i've ended up doing that have made me
feel the best which is you know i said
that one night when we went out and i
just had like i know i went rampage and
was super over confident and like had
like a lot of fun i want to go out and
feel like that all the time like i
always want to have that no [ __ ]
like super confidence like not worried
about anybody when i'm going out like
social events because i do even when we
were joking around like oh sofia sees a
guy behind the scenes she forgets that
she's in front of her just even that
like having the confidence go i don't
need to act a certain way in front of
that person make it i don't need to
double wink at him yeah exactly i don't
need to wink out of my left and right
eye and also look at his eye lips and
other eye it's true i can just do what i
need to do and have that confidence
knowing okay if he wants to come up
he'll come up if he doesn't then i can
go up to him i do i do agree with that
and i also think that for both of us in
terms of our mental health it's been a
big year yeah and i don't think i've
ever addressed how i'm feeling
internally because i
always just try to keep to myself and i
was like okay if i vocalize how i really
feel or what my anxieties and worries
are then i become weak and i'm not as
strong as i want people to perceive me
to be and i think that especially when
we're moving in together
and for me these past few months like
we've hit a lot of low moments but we've
we've risen
like an eagle from the ashes you meet a
phoenix from the ashes yeah
same thing eagle from the ashes
but do you know what i mean and i do i
do after i want to recognize that
because that's really major i mean we
were we freaked out in the beginning of
the year we were like we're not going to
be able to live together and now look at
us we actually rarely fight no not even
us
no not even us together living together
i'm saying in that moment how we were
individually
yeah like you were going through your
show oh yeah i was going through my
stuff and it's like we were doing it
separately but we both yeah no i totally
get what you're saying because i yeah i
mean in the beginning of the year i was
at my like
lowest that's mental health yeah like i
was so bad i don't even think people
realize like how bad it was and so
now i'm like i cannot believe i ever
thought like that like six months ago
and that's a huge i'm like far from it
yeah and i'm like learning more about
that and it's kind of crazy you think
you know yourself but you really every
single year that's the point like you
discover more and more and you're yeah
you're unlocking different parts of
yourself you didn't even know existed
and that's why i wanted to recognize and
bring this up right now because
you just said the person that i was in
the beginning of the year is completely
different from the person that i am now
can you imagine what next year is going
to bring now recognizing who you once
were yeah it's almost like dating
someone you're dating yourself
it's like every single year you're
dating yourself you're on like your
first date and then by the end of the
date or the end of the year you're like
i got to know that person so much more
just you think you knew them before you
don't know at all so i think that's just
also just to be kinder to ourselves and
like i agree if you can't love yourself
how the hell are you going to love
somebody else can i get an amen rupaul
um actually i do want to sort of get
into sophie and i do you remember we um
we did wax and wayne of the week yeah in
the beginning of this podcast we're like
oh we're going to do quirky segments
that we used to stop doing uh which we
should bring back but we decided to do
this thing called wax and wayne of the
week so high in love of the week i was
thinking this might be tough to pick
just one but can you pick a wax in wayne
of the year
okay
my
wane of the year was i would say
a couple months ago where i was going
through that like severely dark
depressing week
of like crying every day when i woke up
and like really just not knowing like
who i was if i was doing the right thing
you know i was like calling mom all the
time and like where i was like just in a
really dark place because i it was
really hard for me to even like get
myself out of that but i did don't worry
i'm all good now and i think my wax of
the year is honestly this like the first
start of this like i love you guys like
this has just opened up a whole new
like door for us and i think that it's
been really amazing to see the show grow
into like the next level and like we're
growing an audience like everyone i
don't know i just i feel like totally it
feels like there's a
purpose and finally a good result that
comes from doing this because i think a
lot of people especially people close to
us were doubting the show and our idea
and now it's finally
they always say like anything anything
that you're growing takes like at least
a year and like it's been a year so when
we got to the studio with this amazing
team and like working with you
it's like
i mean it just shows it's nice to see
your work that you have like a lot of
passion about actually
grow into something else yeah that would
be my
okay that's good yeah
wayne
uh maybe it was
maybe around like march april of this
year i think i was really
it was when we were living in florida
and i'd never dealt with anxiety or
panic attacks before and i was going
through a lot internally because i felt
like every day and i'm sure a lot of
people can relate because we were in
full lockdown so it's really hard for
everyone but i felt like every day was
groundhog day and i didn't think that i
was doing enough and i think a lot of
people
assume
like oh cysteine because you're like you
always tell me like you have it figured
out and you have this in the works and
you're working on that and you know what
you want to do but like i felt like i
was hearing these things from people but
i didn't feel that for myself and so i
just felt such pressure the fact that i
wasn't accomplished and i wasn't
in a relationship and i feel like my my
body it was i was judging myself all the
time and like nothing was like working
and nothing was easy and i was like why
i was just picking myself apart way too
much which i'm happy now to look back
and i try to tell myself like i am stuck
in this skin with this face and this
body and in these big feet and this is
me and so i better learn to like it
because that's that's all you're gonna
get
so that was probably my wayne
and i would agree my wax is definitely
starting on wax with maulka and i think
being in a relationship i've never been
happier in my life than right now it's
actually really sweet you guys i kind of
say i brought this up to sistine
yesterday and we're having dinner it's
just the two of us and i said how nice
is it when you're finally in a really
healthy relationship where you feel
so secure oh my god with the
relationship but you also feel so secure
with yourself because someone's telling
you that you are beautiful enough you're
good enough i didn't believe something
like this existed i honestly didn't
think like feeling these feelings would
happen for me because i was just so used
to the same type of [ __ ] so it's
it's just
like i pinch myself i'm like wow i just
think so many things are
are happening like i get i feel like
we're really good we're going to be
going on a really fun ski trip soon i'm
in a relationship the podcast is
thriving our family lives like
everything is just good everything's
just good yeah it is maybe it's the
holiday season i i i love christmas i'm
telling you it's just a time for love
can we ski no am i gonna get my ankles
yes so maybe it's gonna be also a year
for injury but yeah sophie and i are
going skiing for new year's
with a group of people that are very
good at skating
we just said that at least you have a
boyfriend that can help you i'm just
going to be on the bunny hill no the hot
toddy
all my goal is my goal for this ski trip
is to have the cutest outfit on that
hill no bunny or black diamond my goal
for you is to not break a wrist sophia
you're so uncoordinated with balance you
have zero i'm like very athletic i go
i'll wait train i'll run i'll do all
this stuff but i can't
balance like literally sophia was so bad
at wakeboarding everyone could get up
the first time or the second time i used
to make compilation videos of just her
fall
to funny music yeah i'll do that for
this trip oh god we should probably
share that it's the funniest video ever
it's just me wiping out over and over
and over the worst is when the water
gets up your nose and into your brain
and then you're like
never doing that again but
i i think so too i think this holiday
season is bringing out the best and i
think it's you know what's nice is that
we're wrapping up the year with a
positive mindset yeah you know i was
like worried that it's like the worst
when you're going to the new year and
you're really just down and heavy
and so if you guys are feeling like that
change it up before 2022.
whoa
2022.
what happened to 2021. wait
i thought it was 20 20. i had to almost
catch myself i thought we were in 2022.
or not you thought right now
i also thought today was wednesday
she also thought
this the sky was
oh [ __ ] i don't know what i was trying
to say there oh you're trying to make me
you try to roast me it didn't work oh
god
if my voice sounds weird i've had a sore
throat last week i'm good now so it
sounds kind of
rough so it might sound sexy not really
it's not like a smoker
my thing is when my voice gets raspy it
just goes higher it's not like that sexy
i love when your voice goes high
especially when you're ordering food hi
yes
oh my gosh
does anyone else do that when service is
helping you
for some reason you think that your
normal voice is going to offend them and
so what you do is you switch gears and
then you sound like so much you're like
hi um yeah i couldn't i can do it
so if someone comes up and orders it
i'm trying to see i'm like hi um can i
get the water please that's how i sound
like can i get two waters oh no no just
lemon would be great thanks it's like
your paris hilton the second the
camera's off you're like dude i actually
didn't realize i did that until i was on
a date with the guy and he's like what
was that
what he goes dude he literally became a
polly pocket like what are you doing
pocket i used to love polly pollock i
used to eat the shoes i was gonna say i
used to eat the shoes tell me you didn't
eat the shoes tell me that the flavor
the flavor of the texture
did we choked so chewy
kidding no
you didn't you never ate a poly pocket
shoes that's
no they're not edible don't eat the
shoes they're rubber
it's like our chewing tobacco it's like
you just like spit it out afterwards
it's like chewing
tobacco spitting it out
it is polly pocket shoes are like
chewing tobacco they're addicting
delicious and it was delicious
oh my god i also love those remember
brittany broski the flavor
the flavor
oh god you're calico cats
i used to did you guys collect anything
growing up i used to collect calico cats
until an alarming age yeah um i know
brat stalls oh my god did you see the
super pool and the um the tour bus i
used to have oh yeah we got to our buses
oh god i used to love those um
what
why does it say toddler in the street
oh it's so random i was going for a walk
yesterday and this mom
i couldn't believe my eyes this mom was
standing outside of her car
and on the sidewalk on the sidewalk her
daughter was in one of those little
plastic squatty potties just going
i couldn't believe my eyes are you know
mama's like on the phone and the
daughter's like like
clenching her fist and squeezing really
hard i was like in public what am i
looking at right in public is that a
thing to bring like a travel squatty
potty
thing well obviously she's not potty
trained but i was like can you do it
like in an alley maybe i don't know at
least like
use a diaper if your kid can't i mean it
was hysterical i didn't even know that
was a thing it was a strange walk i saw
that i saw this guy that i felt so bad
he had three dogs he's walking all of
them had sweaters on all the dogs had
sweaters no and but their legs were
going crazy like they didn't know how to
walk in the sweater so it looked like
they were all peg-legged
are you sure he wasn't an influencer no
he just did it for fun yeah they were
christmas sweaters what are your
thoughts what are your thoughts on um
dog outfits dog outfits yeah for
halloween for halloween hilarious
yeah not a really big fan of it because
i always feel bad for the dogs it's
funny when you put glasses on their dogs
he was like huh take a photo but they
hate it they hate it already wearing
clothes the fur is warm enough
i also got asked when i was at the mall
the other day to um be in someone's tick
tock
wait
they ask you too now i'm offended wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait guys white shirt
i thought i was oh my god we're in the
same place yesterday
we always
i think we were at the same place what
time did you go like afternoon or after
my workout we were there at the same
time and did it he was walking around
when he was sitting here when i was
waiting to go that's why i was like oh i
know okay that's weird so
we had this idea that we wanted to talk
about this because yes as you guys all
know um i'm like a first date than no
dates type of girl because you know
we're still single after a couple years
she's just too picky yeah i am too picky
but we were eating dinner and i was like
if i had this on a date it would just
smell atrocious so i just want to go
through a list of things you should not
order
on a date
because christina has a lot of ideas and
i think that people order them and i'm
like you know well i used to make fun of
sophia for doing this but i've sort of
become this person now sophia used to
look up the menu for a restaurant before
she'd go on the date so that she would
know exactly what to order she wouldn't
even have to look at the menu and then
but she'd get the menu and say hmm what
looks good damn well knowing she's
already gonna order the salmon
yeah but you told me i shouldn't order
fish i don't know i was saying why
wouldn't you know although a certain
type of fish okay pesto don't order a
pesto that's gonna get in your teeth two
i ordered a fish one time that had a lot
of bones and a bone got stuck
in my mouth
it was horrible in your throat
or in your mouth just like in my mouth i
don't know how it got lodged in there
like
your mouth
nice it was so painful how about um also
truffle i know we all love truffle it's
just smelly
have you ever kissed someone with like
just rancid breath after having like a
fish or something like dinner like that
that bothers me just like two pieces of
gum or something you're in the back how
about when i offer a piece of gum and
they don't take it i'm like
no or you offer a piece of gum and
they're like are you trying to tell me
your breath smells bad or my breath
smells bad yeah i am yeah
kind of we're gonna make out after like
my dad my dad told me this he's full of
little tidbits
he told me that
one thing you'll never forget about a
person is if they smell bad yeah so
every time you see that person you're
going to associate oh they have b.o or
they had bad breath yeah which is true
it's true like i could think right now
three people with insanely bad me too
also when you're in the industry people
tell other people who smells bad
i'm not kidding i know famously no
slides savage with them most people are
polite ones say
we're not talking about slime in general
i've heard from other people which
influencers
actually have the worst bo and you can
think of one right now yeah
she's the worst b.o ever
if you know what i'm talking about yeah
yes and she's huge so what else would
you order um i wouldn't order anything
with well first i hate olives but i
think it would be garlic i mean i love
garlic duh let's get let's get juicy
you're saying i'm trying to think [ __ ]
that gets oh quinoa don't worry i love
quinoa but don't order it's gonna get in
your teeth also if you don't tell me
that there's food in my teeth and we're
on the date yeah what is your thoughts
on that oh my how many times i've gone
into the bathroom and i've had stuff in
my teeth or an eyelash like or my fake
lashes like falling off oh i had a fake
lash ball like that's the thing tell me
i don't want to sit here for
three more hours well i've gunk in my
teeth damn well knowing you're looking
at my mouth going yuck i get nervous so
i always have to check in between
courses because i know they won't tell
me oh i know they won't i love when i'm
staying at a restaurant i'm near a
mirror but then how do you
know see that would be the worst seat
for you
i could tell because you did this with
at dinner with me the other night there
was a mirror behind me and so you
weren't looking at me once
not once but i was talking like this
i'll tell you exactly what i was doing
there was a reflection of a cute guy at
the other table and we were looking at
each other through the reflections on a
date by the way he was on a date with a
sports illustrated model it was a sports
illustrated model
yeah well i did it for by the way
granted for one second that was a joke
by the way because i wouldn't do that on
a yeah i didn't know by the way when i
was looking at him he was like i thought
it was his sister no first of all he
wasn't with the girl when i was staring
at him and then she walked in
and then i stopped because i don't like
that
the guy's checking a girl on a date
that's weird
don't do that and also don't be the girl
that almost did that
that's weird
what
no i'm saying you i said yeah i said
almost because the girl came in after
yeah yeah yeah so i didn't do that okay
i just thought he was a single guy
sitting on a table under the elf
nope
kale that's it thank you okay
thank you guys for joining us
okay everybody we are back with another
segment of the unsolicited advice
segment
um thank you we'd love to hear your
guys's questions but the only way we're
going to answer them is if you go to the
apple podcast page
leave your question in the ratings in
review section of course give us five
stars we will accept nothing less
and leave your question then that's the
only way we're gonna answer it also
also we want to start bringing back our
bedtime story segment which if you don't
know what that is
get with the program you write in your
funniest
most embarrassing scary sexual whatever
story you feel like sharing we'll leave
your name out of it and we'd love to
read them on the show and sophia and i
occasionally contribute our own so
that's our bedtime story segment which
you can
leave those in the unwaxed email that is
in our instagram bio that was a mouthful
yeah good job so the first one comes
from meg and she wrote
first of all i love you guys second we
love you
my question is how do you get over the
hurt of being treated so badly over a
guy
i feel like i'm still so hurt by this
one guy and we haven't even talked into
each other months but i'm having such a
hard time getting over it i never been
in a relationship before and he was a
lot of my firsts for me so i think
that's part of the reason why i'm still
upset about it i've struggled so much
with self-esteem and confidence and i
feel like he really took advantage of
that i feel like he's going to meet
another great girl and treat her right
but wonder what it was about me that
made him treat me that way now i feel
like i'm in this mindset that i won't be
good enough for anybody and i'm having a
hard time meeting good guys really
struggling with it all and i'm ready to
start feeling good again anyways
absolutely love you both and love the
show
meg i feel like this is something that i
would have written in to a podcast
actually that's true when i was reading
this i thought about sistine a lot like
this is me to a t everything that you're
saying how you feel and then how you're
putting the way he's treating you on
yourself is exactly where i was with
this one guy
that i gave all this attention to and i
put all my eggs in his basket and then
he only wanted me when it was convenient
for him and i'm pretty sure the whole
time he had a girlfriend which i didn't
know about
so and that i instantly looked in the
mirror and i was like well
if he doesn't like me then maybe i'm not
a good enough person i'm not this i'm
not that
you have to
it's hard but you really have to get out
of that because it's not your
responsibility to convince someone to
like you you're a catch i can tell by
the way you write you're a cool chick
okay if he doesn't like you that's his
problem
yeah i feel like i mean i'm just gonna
let you answer this question because i
think you can relate to this the most
and how i got over it was it was hard
and i can't say that i just said one
thing or did one thing and snap my
fingers and i felt better
it bothered me for a very very long time
i tried to do things to distract myself
like working out or like i would get
really invested into like a new band or
genre of music and just try to focus on
that but the fact of the matter is i
even tried journaling which didn't help
me the fact of the matter is i had to
completely mute this person on
everything out of sight out of mind that
was the first thing that really helped
me
do not disturbed his number so every
time he messaged or called i wouldn't
even get the notification for it
and it really just took time like that
was that was the only thing that helped
me it did help when i found another guy
that i liked and i was able to
you know get distracted with someone new
and shiny
but
the wounds of that relationship i still
carry with me today and i think a lot of
people can relate to that like it only
takes one person to truly hurt you and
then you bring it into your future
relationships but that's a habit that
you need to break and my mom told me
this because i was projecting
on my new relationship that is great and
he's done nothing wrong to me and he's
never treated me like any of these other
guys have ever treated me
but i was
responding to him and
doing certain things and expecting
old habits to happen that have happened
to me in the past and i was projecting
it on him my mom said that's not fair to
do to him because
he is
what am i trying to say yeah like
well he's just him so every relationship
you go into is new and it's a new person
it's a new way he's brought up
differently he's not the same person as
you went out with before so don't treat
him like everybody else it's just like
remember how concoli said don't treat
every girl the same that's the thing
that you treat them different every
person you go into a relationship with
you're going to fall in love with them
for a different reason and i really i
really want you to make sure
that
you don't change anything about yourself
and you don't look at yourself
differently you don't think why me this
girl has longer hair she is this she is
that like
you can't do that no and you you cannot
compare because if
he can't
like you or get to know you or want to
understand you or
whatever that that is not
anything to do with you
at all it's him and it's his loss
and i would like to just say um from an
outsider's perspective because you can
assume that going to people like i
always tried to make her feel like she
was the most beautiful important special
person in the world like you cannot rely
on outside factors or people to make you
have the self-worth or the validation
that you're
craving you need to find that with
yourself and that might take time and
that's okay because throughout that time
you're going to grow and learn and love
yourself more just like we were saying
the beginning of this episode how much
we've grown in the last year and look at
sistine now like before
it was really hard for her to find that
really good guy but
don't rely on someone else to give you
that love even if it's a guy or a
girlfriend your parents
be patient focus on what makes you happy
grow into the person and take time and i
do want to just finish on this note when
you say i feel like he's going to meet a
great girl and treat her right
who's to say you're not going to meet a
great guy that'll treat you right as
well also hope that he's treating the
next girl right yeah cause you don't
want that girl to feel the same way that
you did
good good
i am rooting for you meg please write in
i am always here to answer and give
advice because i could we're soul
sisters i can feel you i was there with
you and it does get better it just takes
time yeah
okay that was a good one
this person wrote in help a sister out
from that boogie [ __ ]
love you
first off i want to say that i have
never had siblings growing up and you
two feel just like my older sisters to
me yay that was the goal i love all the
advice you give and just the vibes of
the podcast never stop anyway my
question is
so
i've been dating this guy for two years
we have had a rocky past with two
breakups in those years and a lot of
arguments things are better now as i can
see him putting an honest effort into it
but
i now find myself constantly thinking
about other guys and what it would be
like to date them
should i end the relationship does it
seem like i'm checked out or i'm just
bored because we aren't around each
other as much because of work i
appreciate any and all unsolicited
advice love you girls
ooh i feel like we've all been there um
what i would say too so she's been
dating him for two years
there's it's been rocky with two
breakups they're
working so they don't get to see each
other as well
she's thinking about other guys and
being single okay there's two parts i
want to say this
one part i want to say is the grass
ain't greener and the second part is
don't hold yourself back because you're
feeling bad about how the other person
is going to feel
so
i kind of kind of relate to this because
i was in a really good relationship a
couple years ago and there was nothing
that was really wrong i mean there's
like some bickering with long-term
dating like every relationship but
there was always that thought about what
if what if what if
and it took a really long time for me to
even to come up with the decision of
going okay like i actually do want to do
this and take the next step yeah i had
to also realize that
it's not going to be very easy like
there aren't amazing guys just like
coming up out of nowhere but my goal
wasn't to do that when i was breaking up
you have to find a reason to end it and
it has to be a truly authentic reason
that has to be about yourself and not
about looking for someone else you know
it can't be
you going oh i want to
find someone better because that's what
i deserve like what i i mean yes you
deserve that but
i
i ended things for the only reason
because i wanted to grow with my own
self romantically
you wanted to be single yeah and see
what else is out there and i think that
what made me come to the conclusion was
i know i used to have those thoughts too
and i would always go back and forth
going
but it's good like i don't need to do it
and i can see he's putting an effort but
then at the same time i'm always having
these thoughts if these thoughts are
coming up all the time all the time and
it's not just within just one month or
when you go out or when you go out or
two months
it's constantly like over a longer
period of time
there's something to note and you should
probably go forth and figure out what to
do next because there's obviously
something telling you in your gut
that it's not right it's not right
sometimes your body is telling you in
weird ways that things aren't going to
work out i know there's so many small
signs that i was like i needed to get
out of a relationship that i didn't
realize that i was like oh this is my
body the whole time telling me like if i
was having anxiety when he was like
about to come over or not that he was
doing anything wrong but just like weird
little things it's my body's reaction
saying
you need to
move on yeah but i think also it's also
good to note that if you're having those
thoughts and you're
just feeling like maybe it's a boredom
thing and it's just the routine but you
still love him and you're you don't
think it's worth it to break up right
now
work on the relationship why don't you
tell him that you're feeling this way
tell him
that there's something missing because i
mean i did occasionally i mean maybe i
didn't do that the thing is yeah
i think a lot of the time
we put the blame on the guy
but a relationship is a two-way street
as well yeah and if you're not feeling
that much excitement in it odds are he
isn't either
so
don't be afraid to you know say hey like
let's try doing this let's do something
out of our comfort zone let's try to
spice things up there's so many
different ways that you can go about it
if you're looking for
that exciting good feeling again yeah
but i agree the grass isn't always
greener unless you know for sure that
you don't want this person in your life
anymore then by all means
split yeah well don't rely on dating a
ton of guys as the thrill that you're
looking for because the idea of it as
someone that's a lot more disappointing
no someone has been single for nearly
four years
um and someone that is also three years
old three years single
you think
that you're gonna be single and it's
just gonna be raining men and you're
gonna be like freaking carrie bradshaw
walking down the street and every guy
from a cafe is coming running after you
that is not realistic
and i think sometimes we have this weird
perception in our brain that like single
life is so fun which it is it's not for
me
that's just my thing
but yeah the grass isn't always greener
and sometimes just finding a nice guy
that complements you well
is enough
but then again
if you want to live your single life
live your single life because i'll tell
you this since being single for three
years i am a totally different person in
the dating world
and i think i've actually grown and been
better because the person i was at 21 is
not the person i am at 25. you know like
you're totally a different person so
it's just whether or not you want to
grow and evolve with the person that you
want to grow alone and that's just your
decision to make and what your body is
saying to you
i love unsolicited advice
keep writing in you guys we love doing
this one i do too yeah i want to do like
live calls one day
okay idea okay but
this was yeah the highlight of my week
being here with you guys thank you so
much for tuning in to this week's
episode of the unwax podcast
and we'll see you next tuesday
bye
[Music]
you